i don't need to go out and prove to
anybody
how great matt and i are getting around
or him stand up there and say how great
it's been
look we're having a great time we're
communicating
and the conjecture is for clickbait
news stories you guys can put on your
website
[Music]
that's aaron rodgers yesterday at his
locker and chris sims i know how you
feel about aaron rodgers you may not
like this segment because i got i have
some strong opinions about aaron rodgers
understanding of digital media now i'll
give him this he does understand the
basic economics of digital media you
want people to come to your website you
want people to consume your content you
want people to keep coming back okay i
get that that's fair right what he
doesn't understand is click bait he
understands what click bait is but he
thinks the stories about him and matt
leflore having some sort of friction are
clickbait that's not click bait click
bait is a phony headline or link
somewhere that gets you to click on
something that is just a complete and
total waste of your time because it has
nothing to do with the bait that was
used to get you to click it when we
write about aaron rodgers and what
others write about aaron rodgers saying
things that can be viewed as criticism
of either the matlab floor offense which
doesn't give him the freedom at the line
of scrimmage he would like or the joint
practices with the texans last week
which included aaron rodgers saying it's
not very smart to have special teams
drills that are close to live kickoff
coverage and i'm sure the nflpa is going
to be interested in that when you do
that the article and the headline match
the story is
scrutinizing and criticizing aaron
rodgers comments and that's what's going
on at the core here chris your guy aaron
rodgers doesn't want to be scrutinized
and criticized for calling out matt
leflore he wants to be able to do it on
a drive-by basis where no one really
notices he gets to say what he believes
and he doesn't like it when people say
wait a minute wait a minute here's what
aaron rodgers is really saying and
that's basically in a nutshell my
reaction to this insistence by aaron
rodgers to dismiss these stories as fake
news and click bait like some certain
high-profile politicians are want to do
right well your response yeah well let's
not go there let's not compare him to
some these hi the politicians in there i
don't think it's that drastic one
hey listen chris anybody who doesn't
want to address you on the merits and
just shouts fake news or click bait
that's what they're doing okay they
don't want to address the marriage but
also you're we're we're we fan the flame
a lot and mike i know you're not into
click bait that's not what you're about
but at the same time uh with aaron
rodgers he does get treated a little bit
differently and to say he's a politician
because he's just always honest that's
like the opposite of a politician i mean
he's always honest so i'm never gonna be
overly angry about a guy who's keeping
it real okay it's very refreshing he's
not mr like corporate oh yep whatever
the bosses say i'll do even though it's
horrible for the rest of the team i'll
just say yes and step in line i
appreciate that aspect of them but there
people do fan the flames of aaron
rodgers and things he says and i'm not
and you're guilty of that sometimes too
and i'm going to say that and you know i
love you gladly i'll wear it as a badge
of honor chris because somebody's got to
call these guys out
and if you you say he's always honest i
say he's not tactful and he resents it
when people point out his lack of tact
that's my point okay okay and that
that's fair and hey you're we're allowed
to disagree here and maybe i'm wrong and
yes i i do love watching him play and i
think he's the greatest quarterback ever
and i find him refreshing what he does
but when you write a headline of aaron
rodgers criticism of joint practices
amounts to criticism of matt leflore
when he's just telling that's accurate
well he's just telling me he doesn't
like practice i mean it doesn't mean
he's going like ah matt lafleur made us
pro i don't like this he's just telling
he doesn't ty hilton said the same thing
within the last week there was no
headline about that he said he didn't
like joint practices
chris chris here's the quote i don't
think doing live special team drills in
joint practices is very smart i think
the nflpa is going to look at that for
sure the kickoff especially is one of
the most dangerous plays in football and
that's why they've tweaked different
things over the years close to a live
kickoff drill i don't think is best use
of a joint practice what is wrong with
that what is wrong with that's something
you take to the coach you we talked
about this last week you take that to
matt laflore you you take that public
you're criticizing the guy who decided
to have those drills decided to have
those joint practices
if you got a problem with that you take
it to him you don't take it to the media
we had that discussion last week have i
problem with you i'm taking it to you
i'm not going to talk about it on the
show when you're not on the show like i
did last hour on radio i want to talk
about all the problems i have with you
exactly right how you don't know that he
didn't say that out loud during the
periods of practice when
you don't know he didn't say it to matt
laflin
he is the type of guy that i and from
what i hear that would literally say
that out loud as it was going on like
man we're gonna so so
there's no you know again is it the
tactfulness that you would use or i
would use okay maybe not or that a
reasonable person should be expected to
use in that situation
chris every coach of every sport at
every level would want a player who has
a problem with what the coaches doing to
come to the coach and tell him and and i
here's how it would have gone if what
aaron rodgers should have done instead
of going to the media and saying oh well
why are we doing these live drills and
the nfl pa is going to be up our butts
for sure joe boo before doing all that
you go to matlab floor and say coach
look man i noticed that it looked a
little intense on those kickoff covers
drills i don't know that we should be
doing this is the kind of thing we can
get in trouble for i just want you know
we should be on the same oh you know
what aaron you got a good point because
when matt lafleur finally talked about
it to the media he said he's got a good
point that's a conversation that should
happen behind the closed door of matt
leflore's office not in front of a bunch
of open microphones that's the point
okay but i mean you know again i don't
know if i agree with the headline and
he's not just criticizing matt lavoy
he's
criticizing billy o'brien the nfl in
general he's actually sticking up for
players on the field you know even the
you know people say oh he's complaining
about the offense he never complained
about the offense he just stated the
fact that for 12 years he's been really
good at the line of scrimmage and he
would like to do that nobody has said
he's complained lefour was open to the
conversation but because it's aaron
rodgers it becomes oh complain and oh
he's oh here we go quarterback head
coach things all that and i just don't
always agree with that angle of it so i
know he's not perfect i get that but i
do think that things get blown out of
proportion when it comes to aaron
rodgers and he just gets sick of it and
like i said to start i'm just not gonna
be mad at a guy who's honest all the
time you know i know that it might not
always be the right the right way but
chris i'm not mad at him for it but you
know what you're honest all the time
right yes and when people react to your
honesty do you get upset about it do you
complain about it or do you just deal
with it goes with the territory right i
try to be honest all the time i'd like
to think only time i'm not honest is
when it's inadvertent or accidental that
i always am transparent and truthful
with everything that is going on and if
i tell my complete and total unvarnished
opinion on something yes i know that
there are going to be people who
disagree with it just like they're going
to disagree with this packers fans have
probably thrown their cheese at the tv
by now but the point is you have to be
willing to take the heat that comes with
being honest he doesn't want to take the
heat he wants to make these little sly
comments that are left to interpretation
and god forbid we interpret them in a
way that suggests he is calling someone
out because he doesn't want the heat
that goes along with the things that he
says even though he's being honest about
the things he says that's what i
disagree with okay yeah and i don't and
i don't agree with that point because i
i think he's being honest and he's going
wait you're just making it like about me
and lafleur when i'm being honest and i
don't think he thinks that fair yeah
you're honest i'm honest but we're not
being like portrayed as disagreeing with
our boss when other people are saying oh
i disagree with that honesty so yeah we
could take the heat but we're not being
lumped in there with our bosses to begin
with it it's a little different than the
example you're bringing out so again
okay let me i know not everybody let me
try something else go ahead try this let
me try something else right um
aaron rodgers hasn't complained about
the offense in your estimation but what
he's done is this there's been an
offense selected a system picked by his
coach matt lafleur which entails calling
two plays at the huddle and then at the
line of scrimmage it is up to the
quarterback based upon the application
of predetermined parameters to decide
which of the two to pick it's not up to
the quarterbacks just hey i feel like
doing this play he has parameters he
must follow in picking which of the two
plays to use right he says i want to
have more freedom at the line of
scrimmage right well he's pushing back
against the system that has been picked
by his head coach i don't know how you
can't look at that and say he is
rejecting he's pushing back he's
rebelling against what is being told to
him he should do well it's it's
it's and it's not he's not coming out
saying i don't like this offense but by
saying i want to be able to do something
differently than what this offense calls
for he's implying that well he's not
saying he doesn't do something
differently he's saying he just wants to
add another element an element that like
him and only a handful of quarterbacks
brady and a few others that can handle
all the stuff he does at the line of
scrimmage and you know peter king tells
me it tells me a story because he was up
there at practice and he goes they had
one of these scenarios like you're
talking about two plays called they got
up to the line of scrimmage and it was
like oh man both plays aren't going to
be good and he got everybody on the same
page and got them into a play to where
peter king said matt lefleur after
practice was like man that was amazing
that you did that and you got that so
he's just letting it be known that hey
he's been around for 12 years he's been
pretty awesome for 12 years he's been
why take it public why not do it
privately i don't know he told michael
silver but obviously they had no problem
with it the the article with michael
silver led off with matt leflore talking
about the issue and then going to aaron
rodgers
but here's the but here's the thing this
is the ultimate point yeah you want to
be able to talk about pub just if you if
you're more discreet about these things
i guess if aaron aaron if you're
listening just be more discreet about
the things you say publicly you create
these problems by talking about things
that that lead you into these minefields
why talk publicly about wanting to have
more freedom at the line of scrimmage
deal with that behind closed doors deal
with that on the practice field don't
talk about public you don't talk
publicly about not liking live special
teams drills at joint practices deal
with it properly chris and i shouldn't
complain yeah we just filled our whole
segment on this well because thank you
aaron well he addresses it because he
because if he says it behind closed
doors or says it to the two or three
higher-ups in the organization oh and
then they happen to tell somebody in the
media then we all just make our own
assumptions exactly what we did when he
talked with the audible thing came out
and silver first wrote something about
it we all went in our all different
angles oh gosh here we go aaron rodgers
matt leflore so you know i i just don't
agree with the criticism all the time i
know it's not perfect but i think
everybody overdoes it when it comes to
aaron rodgers
you were in new england yeah would tom
brady have ever said anything like any
of the things aaron rodgers no but matt
lafleur is not bill belichick and that's
the big difference okay bad news packers
fans matt laflore's not bill belichick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports